welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
while we're comming limitations of
conventional tag systems struct Acton xt
applications it is presented by Dennis
caught house scientist and team leader
for self cultivation at IBA Life
Sciences
my name is Judy O'Rourke and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
Rhodes is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Dennis Scott house
I will now turn the presentation over to
him thank you very much for the
introduction and I like to thank let's
point vital meters is great curve for an
event so when you use tax systems you
can use them for two applications you
can use them for the purification of
proteins or you can use them for
immobilization of proteins on surfaces
like eliezer plates or SPR chips in
order to perform essays however as long
as you want to use the taxes and for
those applications you have to find a
compromise because for immobilization
applications you want to have the
binding affinity as high as possible in
order to have a stable immobilization of
the protein of interest on the other
side when you learn computer indication
and it's
if you want to purify your protein under
physiological negative conditions
binding a community that would be so
high will make it impossible to elude
your protein efficiently from other
color so therefore you have to find a
compromise which allows you to from the
color but on the other side immobilize
the protein on ships and yes that's a
kind of impossibility
however hours prepped extra protein xt
system can overcome those limitations
and in the talk today i would like to
give you some at the occasion of
examples of how you can use the twin
spirit extra protein xt system in order
to do both purifying proteins and use
the system for immobilization of
proteins the talk is divided into two
sections in the first part we will look
at there's a purification of twin
structure proteins from XP cho and XP
290 meteor and in the second part I will
give you some applications of how you
can use the system for fvr analysis or
what they use as a switch sense
technology from dynamic biosensors so
first let's have a look to some existing
tags on the market
one group of tags are so-called epitope
tag like supply tank or the Nick tag
these tanks usually provide high protein
purification or I purity but as a
resonant capacity of this tax is very
limited and the capacity is low so
purification using this tech systems are
quite expensive in addition in order to
elude your protein sometimes it's
necessary to change the buffer
conditions to hospital conditions by
piano pH value and that can decorate
your protein another tags are large tax
lights and maltose binding proteins or
DHT tag causes travel being tagged these
types can increase the solubility or the
expression of your protein of interest
but on the
besides it can also have an impact on
other properties of your protein and
that's something you want to avoid in
addition due to the large size they are
highly antigenic and because of this
fact you have to cleave off the tag
before you work with your protein of
interest and animals and that's what
Morgan used you can use the sex own
knobs for purification and lucky avery
conditions because if you do this you
would denature your tag as well so the
most wide spread tack system on the
market is sexism because of the tube
system and the binding capacity of the
resins of high quite very often the
purity of his technically catered
proteins is not high enough in order to
do your following experiment and then
you have to do another purification step
in addition you often have to empirical
data mine which present is best for your
application for example nickel nta
or talen and you have to play around
with the meters or concentrations in the
sample buffer or in the wash buffer in
order to find a compromise between yield
and purity in addition the system has a
binding affinity and an MMO arrange and
that makes them not very well suited for
spr applications because you will never
succumb dissociation of the tap itself
and finally when you purify samples from
the million holes or insect holes you
can cope you require many host cell
proteins because these holes have more
also protease forces to get residuals so
that's how we'll breathe look to the
twins protects 50 xt system and how the
purification with the system works and
the first step on right corner you can
see the loading step you can note
samples from vacuum realize XLI sites is
larger join sigh closets or supernatants
from insect cells or mammalian cell
culture like you directly load your
sample or also strategic ste column and
the protein of interest which is hughes
so the transcript egg will be mounted on
struck a phoenix t by binding
the strapped tag the Bible in binding
pocket ostraca Phoenix team which isn't
really extravagant
once you've bound as a protein of
interest on the matrix you can wash away
a host proteins you can also work very
efficiently under physiological
conditions but you can also use high
detergent concentrations
I saw concentrations etcetera and then
it comes to the evolution evolution you
only have to add biotin to your wash
buffer in order to reduce your protein
because what happens each of the two
tags from twins track has a affinity to
the kleenex teen and nano molar range so
from time to time one of the two tanks
will dissociate from the binding pocket
however is a protein in this capital
place by the second tag but once your
environment into the buffer area the
biotin will be long as a binding pocket
and then after the second tag
dissociation versus profit will be block
2 and that dilutes a protein under very
general conditions and you can work
effectively with physiological
conditions in the system
finally you can regenerate the color by
just any NaOH and go for another
purification round and we have to purity
conferring steps in this protocol first
the specific binding of the host of the
protein of interest use exact red strap
tank and the illusion itself because you
don't change any buffer conditions you
only add biotin at proteins that might
be bound specifically to the resin will
not coil with your protein of interest
so now I want to show you some data from
our study purifying to inspect proteins
from xB supernatants and
ramrod one year ago I talked to Henry -
from thermal and he told me that his
tank users are often having problems
purifying proteins from the exterior
because during the load-in step protein
leaks from the column and in order to
have
futuristic purification it might be
necessary to add a dialyze a step or two
every advance to your supernatant and we
were wondering if we will face the same
problem when we use our twins for extra
txt system so here's an experiment shows
what happens if you purify dystek
protein without any adjustments of
treatments of the supernatant on a
nickel nta column he will be spiked
sherry protein fused to a six histidine
tag to XV show supernatant and we know
that 20 milliliters of so supernatant on
a one-minute our nickel nta column and
you can see that during the loading step
protein this leak from the column
indicated by the white right area in the
upper part of the column so the first
question is is our maximum binding
capacity influenced by substances in XP
weedeater and for this experiment we
look to the maximum binding capacity of
our strategy mix T counts for this
experiment we spied XP Show and XP two
nights free video with three different
proteins and sharing the rat monoclonal
antibody and secreted alkaline
phosphatase all fused to the twins
trapped egg and we adjusted the
concentrations in the supernatant to two
concentrations 100 micrograms per
milliliter or 200 micrograms per
milliliter and all experiments were done
on 200 microlitre strep cracking these t
gravity flow columns this is important
because in gravity from what we cannot
adjust the flow speed so if you look to
the binding capacity which was it a mind
by never e the amount of diluted protein
after the columns were overloaded and
for wash you can see that for an cherry
and phosphatase the protein
concentrations of supernatant had no
significant impact on the maximum
binding capacity for those X P 2 and X
between 9 sweet year however when we
look to the
the antibody we can see that the binding
capacity was affected and decreased was
a lower concentration but this is more
of general chromatography problems and
an issue with a meteor because the
monoclonal antibody is large lizanne and
sherry and secreted alkaline phosphatase
is five times larger and sherry and to
transfer large reserves of fossil taste
the lemon oil constant bottom water
concentration of the antibody is the
supernatant was lower and as it's water
it needs more time to diffuse into the
pores so we have a lower diffusion force
into the pores and due to the very low
residence time of only 20 seconds this
residence time was not enough to allow
us a monoclonal antibody to enter
completely the pores and make use of all
the diversity xt ligands so no residence
time is a result of so use of the
gravity flow column as we cannot adjust
the flow speed here the residence time
was so short
ah in order to verify this we did
another experiment with the xB show
supernatant and in this experiment we
loaded the supernatant on the column
using an automated
pipetting device which allows us to
control the flow speed and adjust a
residence time to a residence time of
two minutes and you can see that by
doing this we increase the binding
capacity for all three proteins and very
more this year the purity and sharing
capacity that you can see with a light
grey line on the right side of the graph
and this is a capacity which we expect
or which is a theoretical maximum and
sherry capacity for stretchy XD column
based on the amount of couple of PVC
ligands and you can see if we increase
the residence time we achieve this
maximum binding capacity and that very
price that there are no interfering
substances in the video that leads to
leakage of protein during the loading
step what we have seen before is a his
security occasion at the beginning
another question is how is our recovery
and purity and in this experiment again
we use biked X P 2 and X P 2 9 3
supernatants with our straight proteins
and our two concentrations but in this
case we only know 75% off so maximum
column capacity on the column again we
wash away impurities and then we
illusions a protein and you can see that
poor Z of sherry and the phosphatase we
recover the brains of the range between
90% and force of monoclonal antibody it
was a little bit lower but again due to
the low residence time 20 seconds this
leads to a little lower recovery
compared to the smaller proteins are by
increasing the residence time you can
overcome this problem the data for the
egg food shows experiment were quite the
same that's why we only throw is xB 293
results and instead of the XP show bar
sink in terms of right such purity of
the purified proteins in the SDS page
she'll analysis and you can see that all
proteins were purified at very high
purity close to 100 percent for the very
protein you can see two bands in the SDS
page but the second is known as a
depredation product of Antares that you
will always find so it's not a real
contamination or purity and you can see
you when you go to the secreted outline
phosphatase that protein concentration
have no impact on purity in another
experiment we wanted to see what happens
if we purified proteins from XP
supernatant at very very low
concentrations the XP systems provide
very high titers but if you have a very
hard for expressed protein even these
powerful systems can result in a low
concentration of protein and supernatant
and in this experiment we spy X patrol
supernatant
with our three proteins but only at a
maximum concentration of 20 micrograms
and if you look to the recovery you can
see that we were able to efficiently
purify all three proteins from the XP
chose supernatant and this experiment we
purified 50 milliliter of X we chose
supernatant over a three hundred
microliters track up txt column on the
right side you can see z SD r DZ SDS
page analysis of the experiment and you
can see that we have high purity faults
we proteins however you can also see two
contaminating bands in every illusion
and the profile looks quite similar to
the profile of an antibody and actually
the provided super maintenance from them
well from XP cells who already a
overexpress a human antibody at a very
high titer around 3 grams per liter so
this is a kind of artificial
contamination which is usually not
present at the exp cho supernatant so in
order to verify this we plotted as a
supernatant you can see this on the left
side of the slide and the illusion
fraction are from the secreted alkaline
phosphatase solution and are proposing
we detected a heavy chain of a human
antibody by an anti human HRP conjugated
active body and you can see that we were
able to detect the heavy chain of this
overexpressed antibody of course in the
supernatant but also in solution which
verifies that this contamination is a
kind of artificial contamination however
it gave us a great opportunity to
challenge our system because we wanted
to see ok how we can do receive in this
challenging purification where we mighty
have high concentrated contaminations
and then we make use of a benefit of the
system because the truth strapped extra
protein xt system has a binding affinity
you know people will make you arrange so
this is the highest binding affinity
available more commercial available tax
systems on the market but as a
ability as I've shown before it's still
reversible but this high affinity now
give us a possibility to perform very
intensive watch procedures in order to
remove contamination without losing our
protein of interest and here we shoot a
little bit was coming on birds but we
watch the columns with 30 Cal volumes or
watch Baja after loading the supernatant
and you can see in the SDS page do you
know the right side but whose makes it
possible to remove the high
overexpressed antibody completely from
the aleutian fraction not since this
experiment shows you quite nicely how
you can use a system for a very
challenging purification applications so
finally we experiment where we
transfected XP 293 cells were secreted
alkaline phosphotase vectors or
monoclonal antibody coding vector
expressed to proteins for four days and
then we purify the supernatant over a
stripper txg high-capacity column and
first it concedes a year between two
through the system was 300 milligrams
per liter for secreted alkaline
phosphatase and eighty six milligrams
political force a rat monoclonal
antibody without any optimization here
and if you go to the purification you
can see that again we were able to
achieve very high purity for all three
proteins and I think these data shows is
that there are no interfering substances
in the XP
chore it's become as free media so the
systems work quite well with our
strategic ste system and the provides
high recovery and purity rates
finally pictures were a thousand words
on the left side you can see the come
from the beginning from the purification
and on the right side you can see what
happens if you directly load ex vitro
supernatant spike will see to inspect
and share
Phoenix II high-capacity column and you
can see that you have a very nice
binding in the upper part of Sakhalin
Ragab and the Deacon of protein during
the loading step so after going to the
purification now we want to see how
strapped turkey needs T and the twin
stripper can be used for immobilization
applications and essays like for SPR
because if you have a binding infinity
in a Pico moment or our range that makes
totally sense to use the system for
immobilizing proteins first let's look
at some advantage there's also strapping
xt system for capturing your ligand
instead of directly color your protein
of interest on the chip
first the ligand is not inactivated or
influenced by the immobilization
procedure itself because you use a
strategy extreme to inspect ramp for
immobilization you can do this under
negative conditions under physiological
conditions I can choose a buffer
condition for immobilization that works
perfect with your protein of interest if
you listen you don't have to modify
Iligan anymore for example doing a bite
innovation step and you have higher
opportunities which enables you to do
long time measurements and measure very
high binding affinities between the two
binding partners so can be regenerated
easily by just regenerating these
pertinax TV binding pocket and finally
you don't have to actually get highly
purified in order to immobilize it
because you specifically capture your
ligand out of any sample using shocking
experience at rate strap tag so as a
following data were provided by bio feet
and the first test we wanted to see how
reproducible a weakened immobilized
Phoenix Tianna SPR chip and it's as
experiments for scene 5 viable options
were couples orthopaedic he was cover to
4 cm 5 by 4 tubes and you can see
the results below that the signals that
were obtained for an issue after each
coupling were very reproducible like you
can see it also from the curves that the
coupling procedure was highly
reproducible
in the next step we captured three
different trims from proteins and sherea
at the end of monoclonal antibody and
kept the age on the tubes that were
quoted with subtract enix T so we
captured the protein by loadings of
protein on the tube and then after was
regenerated to shift by three injections
he was a memorial to an idiom
hydrochloride and each bar you can see
in the graph represent one capture step
and the 3d injections wand regretted
generation steps so this is experiments
we did 12 capturing and regeneration
subtotal and you can see that the
signals for each capturing step for all
three proteins very reproducible was a
CP value below 1% and that we were able
to regenerate the chip completely after
the third injection and therefore you
can use this many times and get a high
reproducible measurement of your bound
protein we also tested a larger kind of
to the CV 202 from something and this
studies were done by the University of
Applied Sciences and people felt and
here we coupled an anti ce4 fib fused to
a twin strap tank on a 13 X T coated
sonntag tune and again you can see that
we get very reproducible signals and the
capturing step and also a regeneration
of chip using granite onion hyper karate
so these data were provided by an X an
organism and here you can see the coming
of a GPCR protein on a soccer team
extinct ownership by using the twins
and you can see that we have your very
stable signal over a long measurement
time which verifies is very high binding
affinity of the twin strap tech to strap
a txt and it also shows is that the
system works very well with detergent
and yet immobilization of membrane
proteins as the air is one way how you
can measure our binding affinities and
kinetics but there are also existing
alternatives and one very interesting
alternative is a switch sense technology
that can be also used for kinetic
studies and measuring binding affinities
but also for many other applications and
this technology is provided by the 95
sensors and they provided the following
data which are from their development of
a strategic Steve chill first a brief
look to how the system works the switch
sends technology you have double
stranded DNA and one strand is coupled
to a fluorescent dye and the other
strand is coupled to your analyte or in
this case to extract enix T so once you
apply current on the chip surface the
DNA will be pulled down to the chip
surface and there is a progressive
signal is quenched so at the moment
where you now bind the protein to
traffic txt or then another protein
through the already immobilized ligand
you will increase as a friction
coefficient to use a larger size of the
whole complex and this we use the
movement speed when the double strand
DNA is pulled down to the chain and
therefore influence of quenching signal
and that gives you a dynamic response
that you can see on the left side so the
large source of protein is or is the
more protein is bound to the children
the higher is this signal you can use
this technology for binding studies I'm
Erin Keeley on KD up or KD values or
identity effects you can also
use it for measuring strokes diameter
smatterings amount of diamonds tramps or
recognizing your samples or
configuration changes of your protein
and furthermore you can do stability
studies with this technology so it's
experimental at the upper part of the
presentation you can see the association
of dissociation rate of a twin strategy
of peas that was coupled honest
critiques he functionalized switch
censorship and you can see that we have
high association rates and that we have
a very low dissociation of the sample
and the KD value which was determined
with this technology here was 64 people
also very very high affinity and in
contrast when you measure the binding
affinity also his technical NTA binding
was the same system you will see for
binding affinity in the range of two
nano Varya so we have a significant
higher binding affinity for our system
in the experiment below you can see is a
binding of the twins from protein a on
the struck a Phoenix T's which sends to
and after that program an antibody was
coupled to protein a the antibody was
our doula and this binding is very well
characterized in the literature so it
was possible to compare the values we
achieve with the strap a Phoenix t2 to
the literature volumes and they agreed
very well which shows you that you can
use a strap of T extension instead of a
covalent coupling of your protein of
your ligand in order to capture finally
the protein that you are interested in
or to measure by the kinetics another
thing you can do with the technology as
shown in this slide here
dynamic bouncing do I use of strap
Avenue because the study was done before
the Phoenix teacher was a viable but
also same
can be performed with tactics teachers
so you can see that once streptavidin
was bound to the DNA as a effective time
has a specific value of around about six
and a half nanometers once you couple
now find now a biotinylated protein the
effective diameter increased to
seven-and-a-half nanometers and
conformational change of the protein to
an open configuration you have a further
increase in effective diameter which
make it possible to measure the
[Music]
distribution between open and closed
confirmations the advantage of using as
perfecting extensive is that you don't
have to buy too intellectual protein you
can use the same tags that you have
already used for purification but you
still have a very high binding affinity
and that brings me to the summary of
this presentation so strategies T twins
cupcake system is a universal system as
it allows efficient purification of
proteins and immobilization of proteins
with a high binding affinity no people
will make you low range but we still
have a reversible binding that makes it
possible to use the system for
purification as well in addition is
effective and immobilization of kustra
proteins on SPR choose or switch sense
technology but we can also easy purify
proteins at higher purity from mammalian
systems and it's quite compatible with
the XP system providing duties of more
than 98% in most cases and finally the
tank is very short so strap tech has a
minor acid as the preferred pair
consists of 28 a minuses so for most
applications it's not necessarily
complete loss attack and the tagged
proteins were efficiently used in animal
studies from our customers I thank you
for your attention and if you have any
additional question
please do not hesitate to contact me
under the given contact details and have
a look to our website for further
information about our products thank you
very much
Thank You Dennis for that informative
presentation but also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April 30th 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time goodbye